he said that he was selling a hundred
million dollars
of liver supplements
so basically these pills where it's like
instead of like eating liver just
swallow this pill right
and i looked it up on amazon and i did a
bunch of research and i think it's true
i think it's 100 true i think that's how
much he's selling in
in these amazon uh supplements
all right so so we're doing something so
the the contest is this so you go to our
youtube you find our full videos and you
chop them up into little like 10 15 20
second clips whatever you want and you
post it on social media tic tacs the
best one but and you use the hashtag uh
mfmclips that's mfmclips with an s and
you just use that hashtag and we'll find
you but basically the people who make
the best videos typically the best video
means the ones with the most views but
last time we actually gave it to someone
who had the most views and then another
person who had just cool videos anyway
you may turn these episodes into small
clips use that hashtag and we'll give
you five grand based off of quote the
best ones and we're just gonna pick what
we think is the best last time i think
did we give it to two people or three
people last time i think
two at least two people won last time
and it was a win-win right like their
channel blew up they had like hundreds
of thousands of views on individual
videos i think someone hit a million
uh and they won free money so that's
good and the guy who won
or i don't know he was one of the guys
who won he built a business around this
that's now doing a million a year in
sales or north of a million years like
it's doing like 80 000 a month yeah and
he came full circle he emailed me the
other day being like hey i think i could
help drive some growth to your other to
milk road um would you like to pay for
this service and i was like honestly
yeah i would i would like to pay for the
service like good on you for turning
this i find like this need that we had
as a need everybody has which is hey we
make a bunch of good content
can you chop it up package it up find
the good bits and get help them you know
see the light of day so that we get more
exposure
yeah so it's a good idea for everyone to
so that's why you guys should do it so
there's details on mfmpod.com
clips
or if you just go to mfmpod.com you'll
see the details but it's really simple
just chop up our clips or chop up our
videos that you see on youtube use the
mfm clips on pretty much anything any
social media site but honestly just use
tic tac it's the easiest one to go viral
on but if you use it there we'll find
you and then we're going to dm you based
if based on if we'd like it and we'll
give you five thousand dollars very
simple
so
sean what's up dude long time no see i
missed you i know uh dude i feel like i
wrote down so many topics while you were
gone and two things happen number one
i kind of forgot why i was interested in
half of them so i'm like i don't even
know what this note means at this point
like which just shows me that this
podcast is not just for the audience
it's for me to be able to just get these
ideas out of my system and have this
constant muscle of uh
of seeing opportunity seeing ideas and
if i don't have this outlet those just
kind of go nowhere and then they just
sort of like that muscle starts to die
uh so i felt the atrophy the second
thing is out of all these topics that
i've been saving up i'm like dude when
sam comes back i got ammo i got
stockpiles of ammo you know like when
you came back it was like you know
the prepper i was a prepper of ideas and
i just had this whole like you know
underground bunker full of them
and then you sent me this thing about
the savannah bananas and i can't think
about anything else i only want to talk
about this this is the only it is the
only topic i'm interested in so please
introduce this and let's talk about this
i don't want to hear about your trip i
don't hear about your family i don't
hear nothing only savannah bananas
that's a this is a topic that i i did
the same thing so i took like a two week
vacation you took a one week vacation
while i was on vacation i saw this video
and i wrote it down i was like i have to
talk to sean about this
the best way i can describe this thing
is it's like harlem globetrotters but
for baseball and so the story behind
this is basically um
so there's this guy named jesse cole and
he was an amateur baseball player and he
got hurt and he was like well what the
heck what am i going to do now and
there's i actually don't know which
league this is but it's a minor league
baseball league it's called i think it's
called the coastal plains league is that
what it is that's right
and i i actually don't know entirely
what that is i guess is it like a minor
minor league or a proper minor league
i don't know i don't know
so but anyway so it has quote
professional baseball players but i
don't think they make a lot of money and
he bought this team and by bought
savannah georgia had a has a minor
league team and it wasn't doing so well
and they're like jesse do you just want
this just like figure out how to make it
work and we'll just pay you or you could
just you know pay us back when he starts
making a little bit of money
all right so um anyway uh so they
savannah georgia they had a minor league
baseball team they gave it to this guy
jesse cole he bought it but it was like
so little money that he like
overdrafted his bank account which for
by like a couple thousand dollars so he
didn't have any startup money his wife
helped him do it and then
the team said like you know how he's
like how many great how many people like
come to uh come to the games they're
like i don't know like 100 200 sometimes
it's picking up and he's like oh [__]
what did i get myself into yeah and they
give him this stadium and it's
completely empty and he's like what do i
do with the stadium how do i get people
to come he didn't know anything and so
he goes you know what screw it we're
gonna make this one thing we're gonna do
one thing which is make baseball fun
and he has like this naming ceremony and
they're like well what are you gonna
name it like the savannah like you know
trojans or something and he's like no no
no no
everyone this is i want to introduce you
guys to the savannah bananas and it's
like a hilarious uh mascot of just a
banana and they're like wait what's
going on he's like no no so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have fun and so
what they do basically is they have
normal games in the league where they
actually are like trying to win and like
doing real stuff but at the league even
at those games what they do is like the
players will introduce themselves or
like the umpire and there's like crazy
videos on tick tock the umpire when he
goes down to sweep the
uh batter's box he like drops down low
and they play like get low by little
john and it's just like hilarious
they have male cheerleaders they do like
trick plays they have like choreographed
dances that the players do in between
innings they have like um instead of
like a like a hot like hot dance team
they have like a grandmother's dance
team so all the the dancers are really
old and move really slow and stuff like
that and then even other things at the
game so he he said he goes but i got
this team and he's just a baseball
player right he's like i use it he goes
i just realized like um
i don't know anything about how i'm
gonna like make this work but i just put
it all on the line like they basically
sold their home overdrafted their
accounts and like they went all in on
this
and he's like so i've read every walt
disney book and pt barnum book for
inspiration and i realize it's not about
baseball it's about entertainment and
he's like so i'm gonna yeah like we're
not here to be the most winningest minor
league baseball team we're here to have
the most fun and create the most fun
environment that people are going to
want to feel like they belong to and so
he's like you know what are the things i
hate about a baseball game i'm going to
do the exact opposite oh i hate that
there's just ads everywhere in the
stadium okay i'm going to rip all those
down and we're going to put funny things
up instead because i hate um that like
you know just buying like a beer is like
14 you just feel like you're getting
gouged so they switch their ticket
prices to be all inclusive so you buy
ticket unlimited you know food and drink
or whatever it is i don't know how they
do that alcohol but like
that's what he says all inclusive
tickets and then they you know instead
of
you know a baseball's really slow so
they're like it's a two-hour like limit
basically to these games and like
there's no like we don't walk up to the
mound and talk to the pitcher for like
five minutes uh there's no bunts there's
no and they did all these things to
speed up the game and make it more fun
and entertaining and then they also have
like the normal game so they play in the
league and coincidentally in that league
you know they won the championship so
they went from actually being the worst
team to the most winning team
ted lasso [__] yeah so it worked but
then they do this other thing called
banana ball so like in between the
normal games they like continue hiring
the team throughout the off season and
they travel from city to city and they
also host this at their own league or at
their own stadium and they have this
thing called banana ball which means
there's no bunts no visits to the mound
a two-hour limit if someone in the
stands catches a foul ball the batter is
still out
well there's like a video that's like
someone comes to bat they're on stilts
yeah and then throwing out the first
pitch some kid comes out and throws a
banana
right like everything is gimmicked
and their social media uh by the way
they have 4 000 people that comes to
every game look at the tick tocks that i
posted up there did you watch them
they're hilarious i've been seeing these
over the like the last year or so like
the the pitcher does like a funny dance
basically before he throws the pitch and
it's just like it's just so likeable
like this the best way i can describe it
is it's so
likeable you you see it you're like i
wanna i wish i was there i wish i was
having as much fun as those guys are
having and um and like i love that they
don't take this too seriously and boring
the way that it's so counter to
everything everything else you'll see in
sports did you see uh did you ever know
any baseball bros in college like
they're always like fun-loving like
sometimes like hardcore bros like cut
off t-shirts and dip all the time and
they're kind of like fun to make fun of
because they're bros but they're
typically like really really nice and
very fun-loving
they're the real estate guys of of
college in the sense that they're
they're successful but they're the
dumbest group of the jocks like you know
i think
it's like if you meet i don't know like
i don't know who might be dumber but
maybe it's like
i don't know like the the the wrestling
team or something i don't know no way
because
the reason why is with baseball like you
don't have to be in that good of shape
to be awesome at it until like
standing and so yeah what you get really
good at is killing time because
baseball's so boring so you're sitting
in a dugout with your boys or you're out
in the field by yourself trying to amuse
yourself while the ball does not come to
you so that breeds a very uh
self-amusing type of person which is
awesome yeah it doesn't like the bar the
discipline bar isn't exactly like really
high you know like with wrestling you
have to diet and like take it seriously
with baseball not really as much and so
this team it's hilarious and i think
it's a good business i read somewhere it
was doing like six or seven million in
sales but
i could actually see this becoming i
don't know if it's never gonna be like
huge huge like multi-billion but
i think this would be a sick thing to
own i mean it's like it's like it's
probably like what people thought about
wcw or uh what's the wrestling thing
called wwe wwe where it was like a joke
at first and they're like i don't know
man this is pretty fun and like we're
getting into it so it's kind of like
that well i would say this is uh to use
the alex hormazi thing he said on the
pod which was like this is a level two
opportunity
but with done with like level 14
execution right like this is the best
execution
and kind of a pretty crappy
capped opportunity as to how big
something could be like he's built
like if he just did this brand if you
put this level of enthusiasm and
branding into like a d2c product or a
media company or like a casino or like
you know there were such bigger
opportunities and so you know this if
this person ever decided to do something
else you know shut up and take my money
but like
for now it's just like i'm glad that
this is successful i'm glad that this
exists this is very inspiring i sent
this to our team and i was like this is
the level this is what level 12 looks
like if you want to like kick ass with
like uh thinking outside the box and
building an epic brand speaking of level
12 and ddc dude your interview with
moyes was really good i i listened to it
a couple times what does he like he's
very open that's the best part he
typically isn't that open like and and
frankly i don't think he i almost think
he was too open but like he kind of like
made himself a target i think because
he's quite wealthy and he basically you
asked him a question that we have to ask
people all the time you just said so
what do you do with your money and
that's what you said and he goes well
i've got a 50 million just sitting in
short-term bonds
i've got 10 million in real estate and i
basically sat home during the pandemic
because i couldn't travel and i went to
my mom and dad's house and just bought
real estate online
and he just explained all this stuff and
i was like oh man that is so sick that
you're ex you're telling people that i
knew it was good because it's supposed
to be an hour and we went like an hour
which is like
at that point it's not even called like
going over slightly over going over time
it's like no you
you just did a separate second podcast
at the same time like i just kept going
because i was like i really am
interested in what this guy has to say
no he was good what was your favorite
part
um mine was okay so the money part i
think was definitely interesting
the part that's like
i said this on the thing which is
he's like i i gave him this nickname of
bare metal which is like he does
business and entrepreneurship in a way
that is like completely to me
unnecessary
but also awesome like i would not want
to do it that way myself
but i love how hardcore he is about like
he wants to be so close to the action he
just wants action and he wants to be not
just have action like i like action but
i like action i like to sit in the press
box and watch the action from the
comfort of my seat you know and then you
know be able to like you know head out
early before the traffic hits whereas
he's like i'm going to do this he's like
i don't just want to buy real estate i
want to buy real estate from a
foreclosing auction where there's no
pictures on the website and then i want
to have to take like you know those
whatever those giant scissor player
things are called and go snap the lock
off the door and then go in and see what
i got and then i'm gonna like try to
flip this thing and i'm gonna take so
much pride in like this being you know
an extra five thousand dollars a month
of like income and i'm gonna do that 42
times this year because that's where the
opportunity is i'm like holy [__] and
like i'm not gonna do a broker i'm gonna
get my own broker's license and i'm you
know he he was just so like
unnecessarily hardcore about it that it
was awesome to me
he also said
he said like i did customer service
until we were at 25 million dollars in
sales and i had the most i answered the
most customer support tickets of anyone
at the company well yeah yeah he said he
goes i did i was the only service person
until we were at i think it was a lower
number it's like quarter million a month
which is like you know whatever uh a few
million dollars a year in revenue but
then he says even at 25 million even now
or something like that he's like before
i left i was still probably the number
one agent meaning like i don't know if
you ever use the gorgeous like help desk
system but like yeah everybody's a
different agent you could just see the
stats on who's closing a bunch of
tickets and it's like that to me is
insane like i have a d2c business uh you
know way smaller than that
and i i don't know if i've ever answered
customers i think the first like three
months i did some customer service from
my phone
um and then like that was it and even
now like i haven't logged into the
system i have really no idea what's
going on but that's also why he's he him
and why i'm me
like one time he uh that's why he's
successful and i'm happy
one time at the beginning of the
pandemic he was like hey you want to go
buy some credit card debt with me and
he'd like
i don't know i didn't even like get into
it without that
answer was just like yeah
my answer was like absolutely not i'm no
why
of course not and he's like yeah but we
get a 20 yield and like i already like
know how to do it and i'm like
dude i just don't even want to like
explore that i don't even know anything
about that and he was like all right
well i'm gonna go buy this you know i
forget but like millions of dollars of
credit card debt and we're gonna it was
just crazy that he was saying that i'm
pretty sure they own he owns like a
hundred single family homes which if you
talk to any a lot of people in real
estate they would say like single family
homes that's just it's not economical
it's not an interesting thing you always
should do a bigger so you get bigger
apartments you get economies of scale
and he totally
does like the most hardcore thing there
is
yeah and i think the way they bought
those was like during the 2008 2009 like
crash
uh when like you know there's the
subprime you know mortgage crisis people
couldn't afford their homes basically so
homes were getting foreclosed on or
whatever i think what they did was they
just drove into a neighborhood and they
just walked like door to door and i
think it was like oh this house is for
sale we'll buy this one and then the
next one hey are you moving out would
you sell the yeah and so they bought
them all it's almost like a multi-family
complex it's like i think they bought
like 25 that were in the same
neighborhood or something like that
and they did it that's like it was like
their dad and then the two brothers and
they just like
just like walked around and bought a
bunch of homes in one summer
which is like you know the best family
bonding that you could think of one time
i was like moyes why are you like buying
these single family homes and why are
you selling deodorant why don't you do
software or something that's better like
in easier and he goes i'm i'm a merchant
that's all i know he goes all i know is
he said he's a merchant and i think of
like my grandfather's grandfather was a
merchant
i think of like a guy from like the
bible who like brings jesus like murr
he's like a merchant you know and he's
like i'm a merchant this is what i do
so anyway i thought that podcast was
really good uh that was that was great
yeah he's amazing he's really he's
really interesting and he doesn't like
hold back
which i think is like just makes him
very entertaining too right like
i told him this echo your brother's one
of my best friends i think he's you know
he might be smarter and better than you
at business but
you're a way better podcast guess
because you're gonna like
he's like he wants to mix it up and he
wants to he says his opinions and he
doesn't see why he shouldn't be saying
his opinions and i love that because
like in a world full of kind of like
cowardly kind of people where it's like
fear-based uh
it's really nice to see somebody who's
not afraid to just say what they think
and what they do
and be like yeah you can make fun of me
if you think and sure some of the things
i do are stupid but like
okay
and
did you um did you talk about luna yet
uh no i don't think so i don't think
i've done a podcast i was in hawaii when
it happened i was like on a beach
and then uh like luna crashed and i was
like which is like literally zero and i
was like oh man and like for a day or
two i just like
um
like like kind of [__] up my vacation
in a way but not because i was like
doing something like i didn't even have
access to my like my wallets not just
like on in the cloud so like
i just wasn't home i couldn't even sell
if i wanted to i couldn't do anything
really um and then i didn't even want to
be doing something i was like i want to
be enjoying this vacation you know you
tell me what happened can you tell me
like you had told me you're like luna's
kind of cool and you're you told me like
six or eight weeks ago yeah actually so
i did something cool too in the last few
days you'll see it come out i
i
i went really over the top with a piece
of content i haven't done this since i
did that clubhouse thread that was
extremely over the top but i was like i
kind of find this entertaining and this
might hit and the clubhouse one like
really hit hit like i don't know like 20
million people saw that thing
i did that again with the luna stuff
where i recorded i basically am creating
like a um almost like a john oliver
style
show you know his show last week tonight
or whatever
where he just kind of like dismantles
one topic for like 15 minutes and it's
like but it's peppered with jokes i did
that on the lunar thing so that's going
to come out last day or two but that was
a very fun exercise to try to like so
tell me well actually try to be funny
but the story is i guess for those who
don't know okay so
um
here's the short ver here's the short
version of the story short version of
the story is you have bitcoin gets big
has this like anonymous creator and it's
supposed to do like one thing really
well which is like basically this like
digital gold and then you have ethereum
gets really big and it's got this guy
vitalik he becomes the next cult hero
first it was satoshi for bitcoin then it
becomes metallic and metallic solves a
major problem with bitcoin which is that
he makes it programmable and ethereum
takes off and ethereum's more
programmable form of money but both
bitcoin and ethereum have like one major
problem which is that they're not very
good as actual currencies right they're
called cryptocurrencies but you don't
use them as a day-to-day currency you
don't use them to go buy stuff and this
is for like a variety of reasons right
like bitcoin if you try to spend it
you'll get taxed as if you just sold a
home every time you do a transaction and
then the merchant doesn't want it
because they're like oh [__] what
tomorrow this is going to go down 20
price like dude i'm not trying to invest
i just need money to pay for tomorrow's
inventory like i don't want to take this
in my coffee shop and so it's not really
you those aren't really you so basically
there's this idea of creating stable
coins there's a coin that's always going
to be worth one dollar and like
this is the spoiler it's like
you know you don't want it to not be
worth one dollar which is what happened
with with the tarot project but like
um
you know it's supposed to be worth one
dollar so the way that most people did
it the big ones usdc tether those are
the two big ones
they're like it's basically like um
like a safety deposit box you give them
a real dollar they'll give you a digital
dollar and if you ever want a real
dollar back they're like i promise it's
in the bank vault whenever you need it
come back and redeem it
and um and those kind of have some
controversy because crypto people don't
like it because it's like well how do i
know you're not lying like how do i know
you didn't just take all that money in
the bank vault and go spend it or invest
it in some risky way and that's why
people think tether did uh does
and um and also they're like dude what
if the government just cracks down this
one company
like they could just like they have to
operate in some country yeah like it's
centralized the whole it's yeah
centralized this decentralization thing
isn't real so at that point so okay so
that's the pro so the pro argument for
this project that came out that's the
project's called tarot and one of the
currencies called luna so the idea was
we need a decentralized stable coin we
really decentralized does that mean that
one person invented tara and then
another person invented luna using
terrorist technology no no terror is
like the name of the company terraform
labs it's like a group of people who
came together said we're going to create
a stable coin and then the stable coin
one of them like it's called ust so you
think about it like the us dollar
version of tara ust
and so that was their stable coin that's
the thing that's always supposed to be
one dollar luna is the tote like luna's
the thing that backs it okay so remember
i said like the in the other version
what backs the digital dollar it's a
real dollar in a bank account and the
way that the us dollar used to work was
what backs the us dollar gold and fort
knox right and that was before we got
off the gold standard but the idea is
like what gives this currency any value
is this like backing currency and so
they were backing it with luna and luna
was meant to be this like
it's like two they basically created two
coins the stable coin and then luna
which goes which can actually go up and
down in price as a stabilizing mechanism
for the stable one so whatever these are
some details they're not super important
to the to what actually happened so but
it was one guy right because i saw like
the founder but like there's a team
right there it's a company okay so it's
like a startup right mark zuckerberg
that's this guy doe quan got it so
dokwan who's do quan he's a pretty
interesting character right because he
basically it's like stanford computer
science uh graduates he starts working
on some like mesh networking internet
thing like that was his first startup
and then he's like oh no crypto is like
the future i'm gonna create the
stablecoin project so
they come out with this idea and there's
basically some people are skeptical
because they've seen
this uh decentralized stablecoin this
this uncollateralized decentralized
algorithmic a bunch of buzzwords but
that's how you describe it stable coin
failed before there was a project like
this called basis cash maybe five years
ago and basis basically raised like i
don't know 80 million dollars or
something like that from like tier like
i don't know andrews and horowitz and a
bunch of other vcs but they didn't even
launch they were like they were like oh
like that we don't know if this
algorithmic thing will will hold so they
kind of returned 85 of the money as like
a failed project
um
so that was like the last big version of
this that had come out and then terror
comes out and so
tara the the difference was they were
like look this works as long as there's
demand for the stable coin
and so they're like where's the demand
come from and at first this i guess i
said it was a short versus actually the
long version story but at first he came
out with us with this idea that was like
look we'll use it for e-commerce because
in e-commerce every time there's a
transaction you know there's like a
three percent credit card fee basically
we can do it at one percent if we use
crypto and so it's like for a merchant
that's like you know that's real money
that you get to save if somebody uses
this this at this option and what they
did was they're like yo we'll pass the
savings to the customer and to the
merchant 50 50. and then they like went
and talked to all these ecommerce
companies in korea where they're from
and they got like 27 large e-commerce
companies including the second biggest
one in in korea to use them so like
imagine like the the like not amazon but
like let's say ebay yeah they got ebay
to use it so everyone's like pretty
hyped they're like oh [__] this is
crypto with a real world real world use
case
finally like real world use case this is
hyped on it i was hyped on it and this
guy because he was on stage he's like
look crypto's full of a bunch of
projects that have no real world use
cases and very low user bases we have
like a real problem that we're solving
and we're gonna and we have real users
we have two million people using our
payments app to do this in korea and i
was like wow awesome i buy it
and then things started to get a little
much invested can you explain yourself i
started i started with 25k and then i
had an opportunity to put in another
200k
as part of like
a bunch of vcs were
buying uh luna like they invested in the
company and they were they got to buy
luna at basically like a 40 discount to
the market rate so at the time was
trading at like almost 100 we got to buy
in at about just under 40. uh but it was
like locked up like it was going to be
released over the number of years so you
did that i did that so i was like oh
dude i like this project anyways if i
get to buy it 50 under market like hell
yeah sign me up and also like these are
all like
tier one like crypto investors like
these
they raised a billion dollars right from
it from from investors so it wasn't like
some random project it was like oh well
these guys are smart they're doing it
all right like that's that validates my
my belief okay i'm gonna go ahead and
and do this
and for a while it looked like a genius
move because
luna was trading at i don't know it hit
like 116 it was like one of the best
performers last year basically how much
were you up by in about a year and a
half luna went from
under a dollar to 116 dollars it did
like 100 x in one year i was in at like
the kind of like the 30 35 price point
overall
of 30 or 30.
no no my my price point my actual price
point was like 35 dollars blended so
then you were you went i was up through
like 750. yeah exactly my 250 was like
750 grand i was like oh great yeah it's
doing well and like this was just the
start it was like it was growing really
fast like not just the price but like
the number of people buying the
stablecoin was going up like it went
like i think the the stablecoin had like
18 billion dollars of tvl or something
like that so it had gotten pretty big
but they had i i kind of noticed i was
like wait they don't talk about the
e-commerce thing ever anymore and that's
because kind of like didn't work like
they basically
it was like working slowly i think like
uh merchants like kind of cared but not
enough consumers didn't really change
their behavior so it wasn't like a sexy
growth story i don't think it was
working they just stopped talking about
it and they started talking about like
um
so what they did was they were like all
right now instead we'll serve the crypto
community itself with a savings rate so
a savings account so basically there was
a savings account on on the network that
was like if you deposit your stable coin
here you get paid 20 interest
on your stable stable coin which is like
kind of amazing right because like if i
take my dollars i go to bank of america
i get yeah but that sounds like some
ponzi scheme [__] it sounds like it
right but it's not i'll tell you why so
it was like
bank of america gives you 0.02 this is
giving you 20
and
and so a lot of critics said exactly you
said which is oh this is a ponzi
and i will argue it is not a ponzi it
was even better than a ponzi yes
so
like what's one up from a ponzi okay so
a ponzi [__] stealing
basically so ponzi is customer a gives
you money you use that money to pay out
customer b then customer b gives you
money because they have faith in it you
use that money you pay out c and d so
you're taking one customer's money
you're paying out the other this was
even better they just created a currency
out of thin air printed like a billion
of it
then
and then they just gave it away right
like and like the market believes they
have value so have you seen on uh what's
that where they have patty just paddy's
dollars on yeah paddy's bucks and all of
a sudden paddy's bucks it's always sunny
yeah that's exactly what happened they
just created their own currency and just
collected the dollars in a way that's
what all currencies are right the us
doll every country does this they create
their own currency and you if you
believe is valuable then it becomes
valuable if you if you cease believing
it's valuable then it devalues and we
see this in different countries and
that's what happened here for a while
people believed it was valuable and they
kept investing in it
um and two things happened one was
everybody knew that this 20 savings
rates not sustainable because
what they were okay the the reality the
joke that was my joke version of
description the reality was when they
raised the billion dollars from
investors they basically were like look
this savings rate is really good
customer acquisitions it's a marketing
budget just like uber subsidizes your
rides like why was an uber ride back
when we all started using uber like 12
when a taxi would have been 28 it's like
because vcs were basically giving money
and they were losing money on the rides
and that's what that's what era was
doing they were losing money on this
savings rate but they were getting a
whole bunch of new customers so like
they got like four million people almost
to create wallets on the network so it
was like
they were buying user acquisition now
you could argue that was either dumb or
not done but it was definitely
unsustainable and everybody kind of
anybody smart knew that that's
unsustainable but it's like hey look i
get rewarded for being early here i'm
gonna get this subsidized earnings
savings rate and that'll go away as this
gets more popular but like cool that's
my benefit for being early that's how
almost every crypto project works
and um it's almost how many many
startups work as well investors
subsidize the usage of your free product
until it's big enough where they'll
start to charge or raise prices
and then to get to the kind of like get
to the crash i care i care about your
take on like what happened to you but to
get to the crash what happened to get to
the crash okay so all along the way
people are like hey uh algorithm is
stable coins they only work when demand
keeps going up
once demand starts to fall this thing
will free fall so yeah you have demand
right now that's why everything looks
good but once this starts to fall it'll
create a death spiral meaning
once people stop wanting usc luna's
price will go down people will start
once luna's price goes starts going down
people start selling luna and uh
basically it was this like interplay
between if
if ust either started to dpeg meaning
instead of being worth a dollar it was
worth 95 cents people will not want it
they'll lose confidence in the in the
stable coin and then as they lose
confidence they'll they'll sell which
will create more supply of luna which
will cause the price of luna to go down
and then that will cause even less
confidence in the whole project and
it'll just death spiral this is the
belief and all along this guy dokwan who
started off like you know seeming like
this smart kind of want to change the
world kind of guy he'd become like kind
of an egomaniac and it was part of his
persona like he was like a donald trump
or elon musk style guy where
if you were if you disagreed with him he
didn't just say you know like i agree
let's agree to disagree like he was like
i will [__] on you i will call you
stupid and poor and like i will make fun
of you is that literally what he said
yeah he would call everybody stupid poor
and he would basically oh my god say
you're all they're all fudsters just
spreading fud which is fear uncertainty
and doubt you know and look they've been
wrong all all the way so far they're
going to keep being wrong and this is
exactly what elon did about people who
were shorting his stock he was like oh
it's going to be the short burn of the
century you guys are gonna look so
stupid and uh and and you know people
are betting against them people betting
for them so anyways yeah but this guy
forgot like the thing to make this work
is you have to be right exactly and he
was right for a while until and and by
the way it's really funny there's one
twitter account that wasn't just saying
hey this ain't gonna work he's like
specifically laid out a like 15-step
plan of like hey look i did the math if
somebody was motivated and had a billion
dollars they could destroy tara which is
currently worth 40 billion so they could
if you put up if you had a billion
dollars of cell pressure i think you
could crack the whole tara project uh it
would have to be like a smart focused
person who would have to time it right
so and that's ex and basically he he
retweeted that was like this is like
famous last words so he goes
man this is the most
r word uh thing i've ever read on
twitter
um
well billionaires if you wait he said
[__] yeah
uh really
yeah what a dumb idiot why would he do
that
would you call him a dumb idiot
well like but like why would you kind of
a dumb idiot would do such name-calling
how can you how can you speak like that
when you're like this like uh like a ceo
of like
donald trump called mexicans rapists and
stuff dude this is like crazy like
people are crazy they do crazy [__] and
then they're basically their fans in his
case we're called lunatics we're like
yeah
and then like they thought that was cool
well i don't know if they thought that
specific wording was cool but in general
his character i mean he renamed himself
stable quan he became a billionaire he
like got a million twitter followers
because he became a cult of personality
similarly
what an idiot though so anyways he
tweets and he's really an idiot because
he go he said this is the most word
thing i've read on on twitter all week
um
and he goes
billionaires who follow me go like um
please go ahead and try this
um and like sure enough like two weeks
later or a week later it's like and try
it they did so basically somebody or
some group it's not confirmed who it is
uh it's not confirmed also that there's
a coordinate attack but it does seem
like it
people started uh somebody started
dumping like a billion dollars worth of
the stable coin which caused the peg to
go down right when you have that much
cell pressure it won't stay worth a
dollar it still slipped to 92 cents and
then it's and then on on top of that
they were also dumping bitcoin which was
the reserve collateral that these guys
are holding so bitcoin's price starts to
go down ust starts to break peg people
start to panic a little bit and they
also started withdrawing from so they
did three things they took it out of
anchor the savings protocol so you saw a
billion dollars worth of whatever like
withdrawals then you saw them sell it
then you saw bitcoin price tanking and
all of a sudden people started getting a
little worried about oh [__] is
something bad happening to tara let me
just go ahead and sell so more people
start to sell and so you see like three
four five billion dollars of sales
happening in a very short period of time
and this also
coincidentally or very planned happened
right when they were doing like a kind
of like imagine you're like oh i'm just
i'm moving houses right now i was like
oh man the doors are open huh
because you're the moving trucks outside
so the doors are open that's basically
what happened they were moving all the
liquidity from the liquidity pool from
one to another and so there wasn't much
there was less shock absorbers than than
you would expect when they started to
sell it went from 100 over 100 to what
what's it at now less than a penny like
fractions of what yeah okay so how much
value was wiped out 40 something billion
dollars 48 billion that is crazy that is
the stable coin went from selling so
that's luna tara the stable coin the ust
was selling at you know it's a dollar
supposed to always be a dollar it goes
92 cents 85 cents so i'm i'm on the
beach in hawaii and i'm just getting
texts from ben yo tara's depending um
and it's like and then it goes down to
70 cents then it shoots back up to 90
giving false hope for a second and then
it plunges to 65 60 50 and i think it's
currently trading i don't know 15 cents
to the dollar so you're you're you're
out 250
i'm at two yeah 225 something like that
how does that feel
uh i mean it feels shitty of course
right like you know lose what did your
wife say
when you're sitting home she doesn't
really care to know nor does she like
want to know the details
i told her i decided well from all of
crypto i was like we lost several
million million dollars in the last like
three months because crypto's just been
selling off like crazy
and she's like okay so like i shouldn't
buy this bag or i should i was like i
think it's a shouldn't right now let's
go ahead and hold off on that i was like
that's the level of conversation we've
had uh about the whole thing like she's
not she's she stresses about micro stuff
like if we have like a late fee or a
parking ticket she'll freak out
but on the big thing she's like very
chill she's like but how do you feel
about that now now that you've lost
you said let's just say three million
dollars like
i guess a couple feelings the first was
i'm not surprised like we went in pretty
eyes wide open which was this is a
risk-reward type bet and you don't just
say that you have to like actually know
what is the risk and the risk was always
nobody's ever made algorithm stable coin
work and by the way so one spoiler uh
this guy doe quan turns out he was also
the anonymous co-founder of basis
that got leaked as well so it's like
dude you know
fool us all once you know
shame on you fullest twice what the hell
is wrong with you that's my take on it
did he did he tweet out like i'm i'm
sorry i'm a dick or like
he's like look we didn't mean for this
to happen obviously like
i have no
because some people are like dude did
you
did you benefit from this in some way
like because that happens at crypto
people like raise much money do much
stuff and then like run away with the
money his claim is no we didn't like we
lost more than anyone on this whole
thing
i feel really bad that this happened and
he's kind of just like you know tail
between his legs a little bit and he's
sulking and he's quieter he's much
quieter now while everybody's like
dancing on his grave deservedly so
because he was cocky as hell right so
like that's what's going on with him
with me it's sort of like all right lost
this money that's not good obviously but
like you know
doesn't feel good it's sort of jarring
like
i've had startup investments go south
but it kind of happens over a longer
period of time this is like you wake up
on tuesday and like
one of your best performing investments
has gone to zero in 24 hours it's quite
jarring to watch the price drop like a
knife um and be pretty helpless like
there's nothing you could really do
about it partially because my lunar
tokens were locked up and partially
because i was away from my computer uh
you know so you know whatever but you're
you're not i would like i mean i would
lose sleep over that i would be like
almost almost
not not quite scarred but like a little
bit like it would almost be a it would
be close to where i would describe it as
traumatic
yeah it's not that um
for me and again i think it's because
i
i mean i write down whenever i do an
investment here's my
here's why i think this is a good
investment and here's what could go
wrong and the one could go wrong was
exactly this which is like
people think that there could be if if
there was a bank run
that this would death spiral i see no
reason that this wouldn't despise if
there's a bank run i don't know what
would cause a bank run but it's possible
and it's like oh what would cause a bank
run was like either a motivated player
created panic at a time when the project
was vulnerable because all the all
markets stock markets crypto markets are
all down and they were moving the
liquidity right so it's like well the
risk kind of played out like that's okay
like it's like you know it's like i've
had pocket aces get cracked before and i
i wouldn't even call luna pocket aces
it's like
i had a flush draw that got beat okay
you know i like to use poker terms like
i got a flashlight i got beat like
that's what happens even if i was a even
if i had a 60 chance of winning okay i
got my money in good but like it wasn't
my life savings now there's a lot of
people who lost a lot more money on this
because they put in a lot of money so to
me there's also like a post-mortem of
like okay there's some rules like you
you don't put more than you know 15 in
any one project because all of them have
these like black swan risks and so you
never want to be that vulnerable to any
one thing is the majority of your net
worth in crypto right now
uh it was not until like
everything cut
not not including private like not
including private businesses no of the
liquid stuff no it's a little less than
half now it's a little more than half
before so you know but like the stock
market also hasn't done great i don't
know i haven't really done it i've lost
so much i don't log into my thing
anymore i i'm just i don't even look at
it yeah for my i'm not gonna do it i'm
not gonna go trade right now so you know
for mental health purposes i don't go
calculate my net worth when it's when
it's so far down
you know there is a good forcing
function i'm like all right great let me
make sure i'm earning money uh working
hard right like it's very easy when when
like over the last year year and a half
let's say since the kind of covid
uh you know money printing system i mean
the whole 10 years has been a bull run
or whatever but like the last year and a
half like [__] just inflated like crazy
so it was like oh man do i even need to
work like
i just look up every day and i made a
whole year's salary in a day like you
know it's kind of demotivating to work
and then this is highly motivating to
work when you start losing a year's
salary per day you know like that starts
to uh you know like add up and so yeah i
don't know like that's i guess my full
reaction to it me too that's exactly
mine as well it's like you just just
make more money
yeah yeah exactly
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of hubspot
hubspot is a crm platform where
everything is fully integrated well i
can see the clients whole history calls
support tickets emails and
here's a test from three days ago i
totally missed
hubspot grow better
uh all right well let me just look
let me switch topics a little bit i want
to tell you something that's kind of uh
i think hilarious dude have you seen the
liver king
uh yeah the guy on instagram
yeah i was doing something he's
describing he said he's super jacked and
he eats like
this is not the same raw food guy right
but he does eat like no a different one
he's more than jacked he looks like the
hulk like yeah he's like comically
jacked
yeah like it's like a funny like it
looks like if you popped him with a pin
he would blow up like a balloon like
like you know what i mean like he looks
swollen and uh uh
he basically like his whole like shtick
and i like research him a little bit is
like
um we aren't men anymore we're soy boys
and like the best way to overcome that
is to get as jacked as possible and live
like a like a manly man right and so
he's got like he's i think he lives in
texas and he's got two kids and he like
the whole family sleeps on like they
don't use beds they like you basically
like sleep on these like wood crates the
floor basically they sleep on the floor
because it's like it's kind of like
where cavemen okay and i think he says
that he eats like a pound a day of raw
liver
and there was a
this is crazy [__] the guy's crazy
and he also says he doesn't do steroids
which is like i i i went and tweeted
about it and a lot of like people
message me who i know who know him
they're like obviously that's not true
he definitely is on steroids and if you
look at him you could just look at him
be like you definitely are doing
something anyway in a gq article he said
that he was selling a hundred million
dollars
of liver supplements
so basically these pills where it's like
instead of like eating liver just
swallow this pill right
and i looked it up on amazon and i did a
bunch of research and
i think it's true i think it's 100 true
i think that's how much he's selling in
in these amazon uh supplements and he
has his own store and he's associated
with like three or four other different
stores so he owns or
uh co-owns this thing called heart and
soil dot co which is all about like
doing just only eating meat and fruit he
owns this other thing called the fittest
dot com which basically if you click at
it's like hardcore propaganda i mean not
necessarily negative but like
what's interesting propaganda and like a
mission statement and a brand but it
says we were once the fittest version of
ourselves descendants of the sole
survivor species of the genius homo and
he explains like you know like why we
need to go back to things the product is
called like honor this product has
fundamentally supports for everyone and
it it's like bone marrow and liver and
then there's another one called fuel and
then another one called ignite i mean
just look at this picture look at this
picture of this guy at the bottom he's
just like this super swoll guy who you
know those like chain links that are
really really heavy that they used to
like pull tires and stuff he's just got
those around his neck and he's like
grunting as he lifts the chain links
with his neck right like it's crazy i
can't even make fun of it because it's
the most make it's it made fun of itself
the most already yeah it's like a
caricature of like what this lifestyle
is about which i'm not like
entirely against this lifestyle i just
think it's hilarious is your lifestyle
by the way what are you talking about no
but
this guy is kind of i think he's an
idiot because
he
because i mean he's clearly doing
something right and i understand he's
like going extreme to sell more stuff
which i'm not against but
he's 100 on gear and he's saying that
he's not so i think it's kind of that's
kind of like this whole premise is based
on kind of a lie uh but anyway he also i
even found out someone at the agency
that he hired so he hired an agency to
get big on social media and he got to
like 2 million followers in like 24
months like a very short amount of time
and so anyway i thought this guy was
interesting and i hadn't i wasn't sure
if you had known about him very
intriguing how many followers does he
have on instagram does it say 1.5
million
what do you think of his supplement
sites does that look do those numbers
see real
you're saying that the um
you're saying that the amazon no i'm
saying all his empire does 100 million
selling supplements on different
platforms yeah it doesn't look like
these are all his like he doesn't own
all these maybe he's like an affiliate
of some of these or something
like in his twitter bio for example he
just has his like ebook he doesn't even
have like a site
and then
this heart and soil one like who are
these guys uh our store he owns uh a
percentage of that he owns a large
percentage of that company as well isn't
this crazy
yeah so paul saladino md is the main guy
this is the carnivore diet guy yeah yeah
the carnivore md it's all these guys
yeah that thing sounds like crazy
yeah and and if you i dig some more
research this liver king is in all the
guy all that guy's photos and in his
like on his about page and things like
that
this um
heart and soil is a good it's a good
brand they do a good job um
i'm i'm gonna steal some of these ideas
from my d2c brand they do some nice so
this company it's called heart and soil
and it's run by this guy named the
carnivore md and he's popular on twitter
and he's like a doctor who says like
basically he only eats meat and fruit
and i joined one of his facebook groups
because i actually did the all meat
thing for like 30 days i wanted to try
and he's got like a 30 day challenge it
was pretty fun and in the group i would
post things like uh
you know like is there any like what's a
good book or like a seems like a good
research that actually goes against this
thing that shows that like all meat is
actually not great and that you should
eat you should be vegetarian
yeah and they literally read
good
questions the premise
yes
they destroyed me and they were like
they just ripped me off you
[Laughter]
they just ripped me apart and i was like
uh okay so anyway this there is a little
i've never been called the n word before
but then i went to the carnivore group
and i asked if meat's good for you
dude they did not like me they didn't
they they were upset at me so anyway i
thought that it was kind of interesting
it is a little bit of a cult but uh well
okay this is like that this whole
episode i think the the thread here is
sort of like these extreme
like these cult cult leaders
um so the banana savannah banana guy
he's basically creating like a cult
right he's creating a brand with rituals
and like members and like a whole thing
thinks outside the box
um the dokuan from tara luna and the
lunatics they you know that was
definitely a cult that oh that was their
name the lunatics that's what like you
know like you know like
i like laser eyes for bitcoin luna luna
that's a great brand yeah exactly
lunatics yeah it was really good again
the party was great tell it all okay
until the cops showed up and uh and took
everybody's money so you know that that
was great um
but you know my personal experience with
that
um
you have this liver king guy i think
he's one can i bring up one more and
we'll just make this definitely i i i
bet you i know who you're gonna say
martin shkreli
i am on board a little bit wait i'm i'm
part of that cult
we're all we're all just what are
scrawling addicts or something i don't
know what we were going to call
ourselves but i think we should they
should we should call ourselves the
creeps
yeah we're all creeps
martin shkreli and the creeps
he uh okay so i have kind of a backstory
with this guy but just in general
explain the explain the famous backstory
okay so martin shkreli if you just
google most hated man in america i think
he comes up as number one at least he
did at the time when i first heard about
him
he is known for or he's known and hated
for
uh being a kind of a price gouger with a
drug so what he did was he owned a
pharmaceutical company that focused on
like small
like less popular drugs that were like
niche and he would and he bought them so
he bought this bug this drug called
daraprim
and he increased the price
from like thirteen dollars to like 500
something dollars i don't know what it
was but the percent was like he
increased it by five thousand percent
and so
people and then immediately the news
picked this up was like oh man and they
started calling him the pharma bro
because
first he did this they were like how
dare you but instead of apologizing and
walking it back he was like
[__] yeah i did i own this i could
charge what i want you know like and and
like this is america that's the price of
this drug and uh yeah i double down he
doubled down and he loves attention and
he's amazing at getting attention
a lot of the attention is hate but he's
amazing at getting it but and he was
only 33 34 when he did this and this was
basically he controlled two
pharmaceutical companies that were each
public at north of a billion in market
cap i think i don't know i don't know i
can't i can't confirm those that might
that might be right but he also had a
hedge fund before that where he invested
in biotech stocks yeah just like he had
done big things and he was he's a very
smart guy
now people think he's a crook so some
people said he was a crook because he
raised the price of the drug that's not
a crime that's just something you don't
like then he actually got indicted and
went to jail for doing something that
was uh legal which i think was like he
basically
paid investors from one company with
like the stock of his other company and
then like didn't
wasn't clear or something like that i
don't know exactly what he went to jail
for because there's any way for two
he went back to jail or his like like he
didn't get released early or something
like that for threatening hillary
clinton he didn't really threaten her
but he like made like a like a stupid
joke on twitter yeah uh
yeah anyway so he he just got out last
week that's kind of the funny part of
this so he gets out
and uh it's like you know i don't know
who's like a famous person that like
everybody wanted to be freed it's like a
free young thug or whoever like martha
stewart yeah free martha like whatever
there was a group of people that were
excited about his his arrival i was
excited too because i enjoy reality tv i
enjoy you know the drama he's like our
version of kim he's he's our kim k he's
that's exactly what he is exactly so i
wanted to see a plow and so he comes
back and i just started thinking about
shkreli in general so i have a couple
ways we can go we can go of
things i find very interesting slash
borderline admire about the way he does
things and then there's
what he has been up to in prison and
what's interesting there where do you
want to go i have both
i like both of those so what has he been
up up to in prison and the back story
you you actually need to mention this
the back story was he was an early user
of your product blab and i spoke to him
a couple times on blab and when the
hustle first launched we were in our
first office so this was in the first
six months we um one of our reporters
was this young woman named brina who was
you know like a pretty uh like a
good-looking woman and he she dm'd him
for a story and he was like hey do you
just want to like fly up here and we
could like hang out and like he was like
asking her out and uh
so i had i have a little interaction
with them as well so we yeah we had a
app called blab that was basically if
you've seen clubhouse it was clubhouse
before clubhouse and it had video on it
um so it wasn't just audio
and uh it got
sort of popular except you know we tried
using it we tried getting podcasters to
use it we we got some kind of like
marketers to use it for their kind of
like promoting their stuff when we
started getting some bigger brands the
nba started using it ufc started using
it oracle
but none of them could hold a candle to
our number one power user martin shkreli
martin shkreli came on the app and
basically broke the app from day one
first time he came on instantly the room
filled up to like 5 000 people
and it was more people that we had ever
had in one room before that hit our max
limit we were like who is this guy
that's when i first googled and found
he's the most hated man in america
and um
he was famous enough to draw a ton of
people in
but he was not famous enough to have
other [__] to do which was the perfect
sweet spot which as i said he is the
most lethal weapon in social media uh he
has since been surpassed by donald trump
and elon musk
as the most lethal weapon in social
media but before that it was martin
shkreli and the reason i say that is
because
um
he
creates a ton of content so he would go
on blab every day from about 5 p.m till
2 in the morning
he would be on that whole time
um and he was the master at creating
nightly entertainment like you know
jimmy fallon
jay leno
you guys can't touch this guy in terms
of nightly entertainment because he has
no producers no script no nothing he
would hop on and somehow or another he
would cause enough ruckus that this room
would have thousands of people in it all
night long watching it they were hooked
to it and we would see this in our data
like people wanted us to kick him off
because again he's a bad guy for raising
the price of this drug and like he said
this thing that wasn't cool but this guy
was driving in hundreds of thousands of
new users to us every single month and
so i was like i'm not trying to kick
this guy off like this guy's like you
know he's where the action's at um this
was a
2017-2018 canceled culture wasn't a
thing yet yeah and i was like dude i'm a
startup i'm gonna do what it takes to
get off the ground like yeah
bitcoin used the silk road to like get
off the ground and like you know youtube
started as a dating site and facebook
you know before this he did face mash
comparing like which girl's hotter like
okay not everything starts with like the
most like clean cut you know i think
airbnb started by like faking and
scraping you know craigslist sites and
you know emailing them as fake people
saying i'd love to book your thing can
you just list on airbnb like dude people
do what they have to do to get your
project started started
and so we had shkreli and i used to
watch at first what i noticed was
everybody who came in came in to throw
stones
at this evil man who raised the price of
this drug
but he did not sit there and apologize
or whimper he like fought back and he
would give his side of the argument he
would invite you up for a debate and
that's when you saw
how
how strongly held opinions could be with
no logical backing with no real
rationale behind it the argument was so
hollow and this was not just like
average people uh people who were like
very successful business people come on
trying to like kind of um
stand on their head you know be on their
high horse uh you know telling him what
he should do and then he would like
dismantle their argument
journalists from cnn and other places
would come on he would dismantle them
um and he's doing a combination of like
a making fun of them b hitting on them
and c breaking down their logical
arguments all at the same time i've
never seen anything like it and i just
thought wow this guy is very
entertaining i don't agree with
everything he's saying but i think he's
very entertaining and the data doesn't
lie he is very entertaining he he's and
i think
later on later on in some of the blabs
he would have like these like cute women
in the background and they like clearly
i just met him on blab and he was just
like hey i'll fly you out you want to
hang out this is what started happening
everybody started off hating him so
after about three weeks he developed an
army of believers of people who were
there's a guy who became creeps yeah the
creeps and so this guy came on his name
was young shkreli and he and when martin
was tired or had to go eat young shrilly
would go hold court and he would just be
like an extreme knockoff version of
martin and he would just hold court
defending him until martin came back to
defend himself and then all these women
started joining and they loved him and
they would just hang out there all the
time and they were like when they were
not like cam girls or model they were
like actual models fashion models cam
girls only fans people whoever and they
would get on and they would just be like
you know martin just like i don't know i
would date you and they would just get
on and they were so the room was always
filled with like his posse and it was
like you go to like you know where a mob
lord is that and he's got his goons and
he had his goons dude and his army was
just growing by within a couple months
the number of people who loved him
outweighed the number of people who
hated him and it was like the most
surprising thing it was like watching a
cult form in real time it was
fascinating and i remember the cnn
journalist came on and she was like
martin i you know i know everybody kind
of you know attacks you but i don't want
to attack you i just want to ask you
some questions he's like well you're on
my show let's go she's like no no i want
you to come on cnn he's like this is
better than cnn he's like you're on my
show you have questions let's go these
are my terms you can ask any question
you want no holds barred right here
right now and if you're not prepared
come back and prepare but you could do
it right here on my show and she's like
i'm not gonna do that martin i can only
do it there he's like and he's like he's
like all right fine come with me to my
fundraiser gala tonight i'll fly you out
he bought it goes a screen share he buys
her a plane ticket and like he's like
what's your email address i'm sending
this to you and she's like i'm not going
on a date with you martin and he's like
who said it to date uh
he's like you know he's just playing
people perfectly didn't didn't they
didn't she end up quitting one of the
one of the women who hollered at him
from washington post ended up quitting
the job
and so this is part of what's remarkable
when he goes to jail this woman from
washbow or someplace is assigned to
cover him or cover the story
falls in love with him breaks up like
she has a family she has a husband kids
i think
leaves them for martin falls in love
with martin while he's in prison
and then martin breaks her heart and
she's heartbroken now and like you know
whatever she gave it all up she gave up
her career and her family for martin and
fell in love with him this guy's got
some cult leader [__] to him so anyways
he did some crazy stuff when he was on
blab like he would
he was so loyal to his army that he'd be
like i'm i got a date tonight but don't
worry i'm leaving blab on so he would
leave it on in the other room and you
could eavesdrop and overhear his date
which is again oh my god prime time
entertainment
is it wrong yeah is it entertaining yeah
it is and so this guy was phenomenal
anyway so i found this guy interesting
he would also do things so like from a
marketing perspective i was observing
how is this guy staying relevant like
that drug [__] was years ago like what
how is he staying relevant he would just
do stuff so like wu-tang clan had an
album that they were selling like a
one-of-one for their biggest fans he
bought it for two million dollars so now
this guy that they didn't want so they
even got a feud with him
he had this thing and then on blab he
would play like snippets like 10 seconds
of the album and no one's ever heard it
before besides him but he would just
like tease it dangle it um like the
original nft when um there was like some
building for sale in times square he
tried to buy it for 10 million dollars
to like erect a statue of himself in
times square and again it gets covered
so he was just newsjacking constantly he
was just hijacking the dudes and putting
his own money
did he have money when he got arrested
or like because
i think he was actually like he they he
showed a brokerage account that had like
70 million dollars in it yeah i think he
had like somewhere between 50 and 75
million dollars if i remember at the
time but then he like had to declare
bankruptcy
yeah and i think at one point ironically
his attorney that was defending him
raised his price by five thousand
percent and started charging him sixty
thousand dollars per hour and like i
don't know if this is real or not but
martin came out the news was like this
is outrageous and like people are like
dude the irony you know pot calling the
kettle black i was like of course this
is just another article he wanted
written about him and like he's just a
master of getting attention he did so
many things like this i can't even count
the number of things he did like this i
was like wow this guy just knows how to
stay in the cycle and i constantly like
reinvent himself because then he would
like just when he pushes you away he'd
lure you back in so like for example on
saturday friday nights he would hold
like you know his nightly blab thing
where he's at thousands of people and
it's like a roast session and he's
saying outlandish [__] and like you just
feel yucky for being in there and then
saturday morning he would wake up at
eight in the morning and he would do a
live finance like session where he would
teach you how to analyze stocks and it
was great phenomenal and i watched a
bunch of them they're still on youtube
you can go watch them he is so he's very
smart and he was so thoughtful and
patient as a teacher he's a he's a
fantastic teacher and so anyway so
that's like the backstory so anyways he
gets out and he said they're like how's
prison right he immediately he gets out
he immediately jumps on
um
on twitter spaces oh by the way actually
that's another funny story when he had
to go speak in front of
congress or
yeah congress i guess he had to go
testify
um he goes there and he just with a smug
look kept saying like i i will take the
fifth amendment you know i choose to
elect my my fifth amendment well rights
to not speak he just said that on loop
for an hour but he was smiling he was
smugly smiling and just pissing them off
and he was drawing the whole time
and then he gets as soon as he left the
record he jumped on blab from his phone
on the train
and he goes
all right who wants to see my drawings
he shows his drawings of like dicks and
stuff like that that he was drawing on
his piece of paper and he's live the the
hearing was still going on and he
embedded it in one screen and he was
just talking mad [__] about the congress
people in the other screen at the same
time again it was just like high level
social media usage so anyways he got on
twitter spaces and they're like how was
prison he goes
oh it was awesome he's like he's talking
about the prison system and like how
unjust it is and how you know he's like
you know 95 of the people that were in
there um you know had like traumatic
childhood issues with parents and stuff
like that he's like i hustled out like
other people's lockers you know where i
so i could store more books
and um
and he's like he basically was like so
what was his like summary stuff so first
he's been blogging have you read his
blog from prison no but what did he say
about prison he was he i mean i bet you
he was actually well respected there
yeah he's like
everyone's like tell me some stories
yeah exactly
um and so he yeah he was kind of like
you know had his his crew there or
whatever he said he created um a crypto
study group
um so he what did he say he goes
um he goes when everybody else was
working out in prison i would read
because brain gains are all that matters
not muscle gains because he's like
oh my god he's like i created a group
called crypto thugs in prison and it was
just me teaching crypto to um to the
rest of my like my fellow like inmates
or whatever
and he had a bunch of like interesting
stuff so
um
he had a bunch of predictions about
crypto that were in there a bunch of he
read he basically spent his whole time
studying about crypto and artificial
intelligence um and like biohacking and
stuff like that so he's got this blog
post with a [__] ton of predictions
about the future um i'll i'll read you a
couple of his
i'm on his blog it's just it's
martinskewelly.com right uh yeah i think
so
so um let me read you some predictions
on here so 2025 so about three years
from now
self-driving cars are the successor to
mobile computing they trend upwards
people spend eight hours a day in your
car
um tesla nears 10 trillion market cap
musk becomes the first trillionaire
2026 an ai generated maybe for song gets
created with zero human editing and
direct participation and charts on
billboard
uh 2013 or 2030. um
virtual reality slash metaverse is
ubiquitous widely used all you needed
was a comfortable ergonomic optical
interface that's what was the limiting
item
i think he's uh wrong on that one 2030
vehicles uh self-driving cars reached
majority penetration in the u.s car
accidents dropped by more than 50
percent and he just keeps going he goes
out to like 2050 he's making predictions
as to things like you know 2050 lifespan
for a newborn is now 100 to 125. 90 of
non-surgical medicine is automated
um
blah blah blah like most contract law is
automated on as automated on chain and
so he keeps going now right or wrong you
could disagree with all these but he's
just a very interesting thinker a very
interesting guy you follow right and he
does these book reviews that are like
very hilarious where he's like this book
three out of five
uh you know first three fourths giant
waste of time last fourth interesting
about this topic it's like oh good like
you saved me much time reading that book
like i kind of trust your opinion on
these things um and so i don't know his
blog is worth a read
we uh i i tweeted out asked to get him
on the pod but i had no twitter handle
to tag i didn't know who he was or you
know which it was kind of hidden we
maybe found the right one um yeah but we
uh
we should get him on i feel like we're
big enough that we can get him and he's
an interesting guy enough
he's a he's um i don't like giving our
audience like our platform to people who
i think are full of [__] like for
example jordan belfort i wouldn't want i
wouldn't want him on dude i would would
you
yeah it's the same remember people were
like oh i can't believe you guys had tai
lopez on
it's like well well dude there's a scale
would i want to talk to this person
that's the test if i would want to talk
to this person that means they're
interesting just because you're on the
podcast doesn't mean we say this person
is awesome and legit
i agree but i don't want to endorse
certain things and maybe like well how
are we endorsing
yeah i don't know but this is like you
don't wrestle with this at all
no i actually find that stupid they
people do this to joe rogan others as
well jack
why would you give him the platform to
say his like stupid stuff it's like
dude i'm gonna i'm gonna have a
conversation with him
or the he or she and
because they're interesting to me i'm
gonna find out maybe they're you know
i'm gonna find out what they have to say
if they say something silly or stupid
i'm gonna try to push back and give my
point of view and the listeners should
be smart enough to come to their own
opinion about things and in fact
you know the right way to like
the right way to make somebody the right
way to like counteract like speech you
disagree with is not to suppress it but
to like
enable enable bring it to light right
like put the sun is the best
disinfectant type of thing like bring it
to light and then let people make an
informed decision off of what they heard
and um
you know well i i i i i would really
forcing at all just to have someone on
the podcast i'm on board with that i and
admittedly i'm wrestling with how i my
opinion on it like do you think they
should give a bad wolf of wall street
because jordan belfort is a bad guy like
no he'll know no but i don't want to and
they glorified it dude they put leo
dicaprio
i actually don't
i i like by myself watching that movie
i'm like you know i don't want to watch
this this guy was a piece of [__] he's
robbed a quarter of a billion dollars
from people and yeah i'm watching this
movie and i'm like oh i want to be like
that
so i like find myself not wanting to
watch it but what i was saying was
martin shkreli is the type of guy who i
actually don't agree with probably a
bunch of the stuff that he's done but
i'm not convinced that he's like an evil
guy i'm i think that he's just a weirdo
and
like when he was smiling at congress i
was like oh i i actually think you're
just weird and you just don't know how
to interact with people i don't i don't
i i i you know what i mean he knew what
he was doing he's a troll
i think he's a troll but i don't i think
it comes from a place if he's just
really awkward
not necessarily of like he's a horrible
guy
yeah i don't know horrible guy
people come up with their own conclusion
you know
i've seen a lot of people say he's a
horrible guy you say why oh because he
raised the price of the drug why is that
bad because then people can't afford it
well you actually know that insurance
pays for 98 of it and then he gave away
the other two percent if you couldn't
afford it through insurance he just gave
it to you
yeah but then insurance costs go up cool
well then you should have a problem with
like these 15 other things like you know
also if these drugs are not like
valuable then there's no research for
these niche diseases so that's why a lot
of these diseases just don't have any r
d budget because there's no value in
them so which is proof that his biggest
crime is having a punchable face exactly
exactly you know what i mean like and
that's a real thing and uh
he was very dislikeable he's dislikeable
because he trolls and he's rude to
people and he makes fun of things and he
like yeah okay cool but that's not a
crime you know but i would love to i
would love to have him and him on and
talk to him because he's the type of guy
i don't think he's a liar shrill
we want to do an episode this is our
open invitation i hope this gets back to
you i'm the guy who made blab we spent
many many hours together in a way on
that platform uh whenever we were
getting ddosed it was because of you i
put up with that [__] so uh you know
give us one give us a solid and come on
the pod
so we'll uh we'll have to attack him
wait is that twitter thing i think
that's a speaker yeah
but is that a secret no because he was
in the twitter spaces under that okay
all right so that'd be cool yeah
[Music]
you